again I try to ban this topic because
it's an emotional one it's like talking
about religion it's like talking about
cryptocurrencies right people end up on
these totally irrational so listeners
come into this please with an open mind
and try to understand and be objective
I'm a quant right there's no emotions
here I have no heart so I always joke
and say it's negative interest rates
crypto and stock buybacks are the three
most religious things in finance all in
one all right let's start with the
basics and then we'll go from there
you're a company doesn't matter your
public private whatever you let's use
public on me say your Apple there's only
five things you can do their money and
that's it the first one which is what
people spend 90% of the time on is the
sexy part is you can reinvest in the
business that means you're building new
plants you're doing research into a new
computer you're hiring new people you're
doing new innovation right that's one
second you can go do M&A you can buy
other companies which traditionally is
actually value destroying on average but
you can go take over other companies add
to your company to extend EF cash so
that's one so one reinvestment company
to M&A three to the extent you have debt
you can pay down debt and then the last
two are ways you return to cash to
shareholders you can pay cash dividend
or you can do a stock buyback that's it
there's nothing else you can do with
your money and the job of a CEO who by
the way most of these guys are not
dummies they may be ego maniacs but
they're not dummies is to pursue any
project that has a the highest return
okay and so let's say you're at Apple
and you have a great idea for a new
teleporter and it's gonna be awesome
good for you put that money there but if
you're a widget factory making widgets
and you don't have like any brilliant
ideas but you're sloughing off billions
of capital what are you supposed to do
with that and you you can't just so most
people you say well you could just go
hire a bunch of people and do all this
R&D well you're just flushing money down
if you don't have ideas that are
reasonable and if you get to a certain
size it gets harder and harder if you're
a hundred billion dollar company if
you're five hundred billion dollar
company these are the old kind of
bloated companies you can't do anything
with that much money so what have they
done historically they go to M&A and
also flush it down the toilet they name
stadiums flush it down the toilet so the
long history by the way you go back
hundreds of years is that the original
reason companies had dividends is
because when you were selling securities
to the public and institutional
investors you had to try to make them a
little more like bonds like hey you can
buy this company and it'll paying you
some sort of like cash return like
interest okay and it's returning cash to
shareholders and so that was the concept
but buybacks this is gonna trigger
everyone but this is finance 101 this is
something you should have learned as a
freshman in college is that buybacks are
the exact same thing as dividends with
only two differences divot buybacks are
more flexible you can do them whenever
you want or stop them they're more tax
efficient dividends are have a worse tax
treatment because you're forced to take
them every year when the company pays
you say you have to have money back
whether you want it or not
and then buybacks can also happen at a
distance from intrinsic value for the
company and that's it
so if the company is trading as stocks
trading an intrinsic value and let's say
theoretically politicians did this they
never will they have the same tax
treatment they're literally the exact
same thing and that's full stop okay
that you cannot argue that fact that is
a one plus one equals two theorem okay
so one way to establish if a rider or a
guru or someone doesn't understand
buybacks is to look at what they just
said take out the word buy back and put
in dividend and if the sentence doesn't
make any sense now or change the message
well then they don't understand or
they're conveying the meaning or they
have an emotionally-charged agenda okay
let's talk about a few more things
by the way not everything is rosy backs
when getting down for the greater
experience of history for the past two
three four hundred years this goes back
to the Dutch East Asia company Dutch he
says it I'm gonna get the wrong get the
name wrong what's the name of the
company anyway it's seventeen hundreds
there's one of those drama scene others
we have on our blog post I got so
frustrated with this topic we have a
blog post it's called FAQ on buybacks
for journalists politicians etc and it
links about the top form things to do
with buybacks I actually saw a great one
flow chart last night from from Joshua
wolf and Michael Malmaison it's this on
Twitter you can posted the show links
for the most of history governments and
investors demanded that companies do
buybacks
because they didn't want CEOs
squandering the money paying themselves
huge salaries doing stupid projects
hoarding it so they said your company
you have to pay dividends you have to do
buybacks because we don't want you to do
dumb stuff and it's funny how the dialog
has changed um so let's fast forward in
the modern era companies have started
doing a lot more buyback since the 1980s
because there's rule that got passed in
the early eighties they made a
particularly easy and gave companies
safe harbor from buybacks okay so in any
given year buybacks started ticking up
in any given year starting in like 97
buybacks have outpaced dividends as they
should because they're more tack for
Fisher okay now there's two parts in
those two separations there's the talk
about buybacks and dividends from the
investor standpoint which we can get to
in a minute and then there's buyback and
dividends from a public policy etc why
do buybacks have a bad name first of all
they got terrible branding whoever came
up with name stock buybacks should be
fired you know it's such like you talk
about like how everyone by his life
insurance back when it's called death
insurance no one would buy it the same
guy the the Chilean toothfish when he
named it Chilean seabass all sudden
everyone buy all right
so buybacks is a terrible terrible
Freight framing for it what it should be
called is flexible tax efficient
dividends okay
Warren Buffett understands this right
look at Berkshire Berkshire has never
paid a dividend and that's not quite
true
it paid one in 1960 it was like 10 cents
and Berkshire famous Warren says he was
famously in the bathroom when they made
this decision because he would never
have made that decision because
dividends force you to take take cash
back my back stubble you can choose to
or not
the things that I think are probably
fair many people associate buybacks with
CEOs and compensation and they say well
these CEOs they have compensation tied
to earnings per share they have options
therefore their only goals increase
earnings per share thus they're doing
buybacks Yatta Yatta those are two
separate issues if you have a [ __ ]
board that is tying CEO compensation to
earnings per share they should be fired
full stop right that has nothing to do
with buybacks okay how you distribute
cash has nothing to do with how you pay
your CEO and your company in the same
genre you have to talk about companies
that also issue shares correct so there
are a lot of tech companies and other
companies to reward employees they issue
stock options all right so that's shared
issuance so you're diluting the
shareholder and on the right hand they
go and buy back the shares okay so it's
somewhat of a wash in many cases I think
that's a fair criticism but it's not a
criticism of buybacks those criticisms
of structure and how boards operate and
that's a policy decision that has
nothing to do with buybacks another
example is people love to take a sets a
sample size of one and they'll look at a
company that has been buying back a
bunch of stock over the past 10 years
and then maybe gets into hard times the
share price goes down they say look how
stupid that was to buy back stock and
now the share price is down that was so
dumb they wasted so much money but many
of those companies were also issuing
dividends and you say the same thing is
simply a return of cash to shareholders
it's the same exact phenomenon now as a
shareholder you should never want to own
an expensive stock so if you're Warren
Buffett
it you have a quantitative measure he
says look we'll buy back shares a
perjurer when they get below I think
it's one point three times look I think
I think that are right around one now so
he's probably buying a bunch of
Berkshire this year this quarter this
month most CEOs don't have that in place
that having been said if you look at the
historical valuations of company that
are companies that are issuing shares
companies that are buying back stock and
companies are buying back a lot of stock
the ones that are issuing shares
traditionally are trading at valuation
premiums the ones that are buying back
stock are trading at valuation discounts
and the ones that are backing up the
truck and buying a boatload
traditionally in trading at valuation
big discounts so on average they've done
a good job it doesn't mean you can't
come up with some company that hasn't
and then the second part is is the
company just poorly managed people don't
talk about hey they wasted a bunch of
money on that new plant in upstate New
York or hey they paid out billions and
dividends they shouldn't they should
have been paying down debt that's a CEO
decision and whether you wanted to lever
up the company or not it's up to you but
on the flip side a lot of companies in
Europe a lot of companies in Japan have
the opposite structure where they have a
ton of cash and they're just very
bloated what you call these zombie
companies all of this having been said
I'm a buyback agnostic doesn't sound
like it but I'm a buyback agnostic a
very simple fix to all of this is
legislature politicians eliminate the
double taxation of dividends okay so you
remove the tax of a company paying
dividends and all of a sudden buybacks
become fairly irrelevant